[Musik]
hallo
juni rufen hallo ja das ganze ist uns
wirklich unglaublich peinlich aber es
handelt sich um ein ärgerliches
missverständnis
ja wir können das aber alles erklären
ja es war normaler betrieb zur
mittagszeit nico saß im hinteren bereich
ja und dann begann inge zu husten
richtig gefährlich sowohl das ging jetzt
das wasser und der husten wurde etwas
besser in lächelte sofort wieder an ging
aber auf toilette um sich regisseur
ich gebe mich schnell frisch machen wir
sind dann zurück in die kirche gegangen
während nico offenbar mitbekamen dass
dinge auf der toilette wieder ein
hustenanfall bekam davon hat mir gar
nichts mitbekommen weil die pegel wurst
angebrannt ist und als ich das in der
key gesehen habe rief ich laut
[Musik]